I'm writing every devil fruit in one
piece to figure out which is the best
one this is the food foodi the brush
brush fruit which allows the user to
create living objects with a brush it
was previously eaten by conjuro a former
samurai from wano and for strength this
fruit allows you to create super strong
weapons or clones to fight for you and
you can even make snakes or ink arrows
to attack your enemies 19 out of 25
points similarly you can paint armor or
a giant castle to protect you and if you
need to get away you can paint an animal
to carry you to safety so another 19
points for d defense however this fruit
is a true work of art when it comes to
special abilities since you can
literally create living objects and
elements like fire and lightning giving
it a perfect 25 points here and of
course it's truly amazing for everyday
use as well since you can make anything
that you want and make it come to life
another 25 points however the fruit does
require that you learn how to paint
really well so minus five points for
that making it into a true Masterpiece
with 83 points and the second place for
now